[Music]
on this wednesday night immunizations
and omicron
how much does the new variant weaken
vaccine protection and is a third dose
the answer as omicron spreads
restrictions return to the uk
plus no laughing matter and it was not
socially distant the uproar over a uk
government christmas party held during
lockdown last year
ottawa joins the ballooning diplomatic
boycott of the beijing olympics the
impact on canada's already strained
relationship with china
name dropping people are ready for this
kind of change the push to rename the
award given to canada's top athlete
and light show we heard a huge boom what
just flew over alberta
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as researchers across the world pieced
together data about the omicron variant
early evidence suggests it may be milder
than delta but it could be more capable
of evading vaccines in south africa
people who have already had covet or
been vaccinated are getting re-infected
now pfizer bioentex says it's found a
third dose of its vaccine will help
control omicron though that study has
not been peer reviewed the omicron
variant is spreading fast it's been
detected now in 57 countries the who
cautioned today it's too early to reach
any conclusions and said that omicron
could change the course of the pandemic
if we allow a mild disease to transmit
unchecked it will generate huge pressure
in the health system which will
decrease the positive outcomes for
people and that's what we've seen
with many before
there are dozens of cases in canada now
and it's expected that number will rise
but questions about just how
transmissible it is and how severely ill
people might become are not answered yet
jamie morocco has our top story tonight
on the preliminary evidence about
vaccine effectiveness
third time's the charm according to
pfizer to keeping kovid's latest variant
at bay
three doses against omikron are almost
equivalent to the two doses
effectiveness we had against
the wild type the original area but the
company which studied blood samples from
omicron infected patients in a lab
setting also found the first two doses
do make a difference against the variant
thanks to our body's multi-line defenses
the first antibodies to fight off a germ
your immune system custom produces an
antibody that attaches to a marker on
the virus called an antigen and signals
the immune system to destroy it we're
not facing the same pitcher the starting
pitcher from 2020 we're now facing you
know the second or third relief picture
at this point in time and each time we
do that we have to adjust as well
early data suggests this is why patients
are appearing more susceptible to
omicron however there is also your t
cell response which pfizer found was
largely unaffected by covin's latest
mutation these cells called cd8 plus
work by hunting for intruders when they
catch a mutated cell in this case a
virus they attach and work to destroy it
that's the importance of having two
branches of our immune system because it
gives us better coverage coverage
ideally enhanced by another shot it may
be that we might need to simply boost
what we already have or it may mean that
we need to tweak
canada's national advisory committee on
immunization recommended boosters for
everyone over 18 last week and both
pfizer and moderna confirmed
strain-specific vaccines
are already in the works we don't
necessarily know everything we need to
about omron yet
but the data that we have is certainly
you know setting up some alarm bells
there you go warning experts say we
can't ignore jamie morocco global news
toronto
in the uk there's fear omicron could be
dominant in two to four weeks the
government says early data appears to
show cases are doubling every two and a
half to three days and it's reimposing
some public health restrictions starting
on monday people in england are urged to
work from home if possible face masks
will be mandatory in most public places
including movie theaters and the nhs
covid pass which proves vaccination or a
negative test result will be needed to
enter nightclubs and other high-capacity
venues
while the picture may get better and i
sincerely hope that it will we know that
the remorseless logic of exponential
growth could lead to a big rise in
hospitalizations therefore sadly in
deaths but the single biggest thing that
every one of us can do is to get our
jabs
at the same time the uk prime minister
boris johnson is apologizing for a video
that surfaced showing one of his staff
laughing about a government christmas
party held last year during the height
of the lockdown as hospitals filled with
the sick and dying he claims he'd been
assured no such party had taken place
crystal gomencing reports on the fallout
with the days ticking down to christmas
covid and contrition topped the british
prime minister's agenda i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
mr speaker because i
was also furious to see that clip
furious at the content of a video
obtained by british broadcaster itv news
this fictional party was a business
meeting
and it was not socially distanced
the mock news conference led by
johnson's former press secretary appears
to confirm a party did take place last
year at number 10. at the time such
gatherings were banned england was in
lockdown
after days of the government denying
there was a party or that any rules were
broken
johnson launched an investigation this
government's handling of the pandemic
has been questioned from the very
beginning and now many are wondering
whether it has the moral authority to
govern those who have lost loved ones
during the course of the pandemic say
the prime minister's continued defense
of his staff and the videos
make them feel sick they were talking
about the it was the the partying and
cheese and wine and then
laughing about social distancing as if
it was some kind of joke and not a
measure that was in place to protect
people's lives amos waldman lost his
grandmother to covet she would have
turned 95 this week the pandemic virus
also put his mother in hospital at
christmas last year
extreme anger really
given the hypocrisy
allegra stratton has now offered a
tearful expression of regret for her
comments and resigned others are being
called on to follow suit
including the prime minister
crystal gamansing global news london
canada has joined a growing list of
countries in a diplomatic boycott of the
2022 winter olympics in beijing prime
minister justin trudeau announced the
move today
we have been very clear
over the past many years of our deep
concerns
around human rights violations
and this
is a continuation of us expressing our
deep concerns for human rights
violations
the government says it spent months
considering what to do about the games
michael couture has more on the decision
and what it means for canada-china
relations
we will not be sending any diplomatic
representation
to the beijing olympic paralympic games
this winter canada is hoping to send a
message to china while still sending its
athletes to the olympics the move
mirrors the diplomatic boycott already
announced by allies like the us uk and
australia if we are concerned about in
fact the erosion going on around the
world on democracy and the rise of
authoritarian regime i think we have to
take a stand
that stand follows china's lengthy
record of human rights violations
particularly for the treatment of the
uyghur muslim minority advocates say
it's a good first step but it doesn't go
far enough i wish canada and other
right-minded countries around the world
should do whatever is necessary to a
full boycott trudeau says that isn't in
the cards canadian athletes were last
kept home from the 1980 moscow games as
a protest of russia's invasion of
afghanistan and this time olympians say
the decision should be left to the
athletes to rob our own athletes of
their own voice and their own
decision-making while we're trying to
promote someone else's human rights it
just doesn't make sense china has
threatened the u.s will pay for its
boycott trudeau wouldn't say if he fears
any fallout but the minister of sport
did say security will be beefed up for
athletes there's already agents that
have been hired to ensure the security
of the athletes and we're still in
discussion with the rcmp the ioc has
remained on the sidelines of any
political debate citing historical
precedence could be the end of the
olympic games as it was the end of the
ancient olympic games when the politics
got involved foreign affairs minister
melenija ali says she'll continue to
raise the diplomatic boycott with g7
counterparts in the coming days in the
hopes that more countries join canada
and other allies to send a strong signal
to china
donna okay mike look at her in ottawa
thank you the state of emergency in
iqaluit over its water crisis has been
extended to december 14th work is
underway to restore the city's water
supply which became contaminated by fuel
the canadian armed forces has been using
mobile purification equipment to make
river water safe to drink it's been
nearly two months since the coluet's 8
000 residents were told not to drink the
tap water
members of an indigenous delegation are
hopeful their audience with pope francis
will still happen even if they don't
know when the visit to the vatican plan
for december has been postponed because
of the rapid spread of the omicron
variant as abigail beeman explains the
delay gives the delegation more time to
collect their thoughts
we're having one of our last meetings
earlier this week and
we're all just yeah we're just getting
really excited and some disappointment
but youth delegate taylor baintacoza
supports postponing the trip it also
gives her more time to strengthen what
she wants to tell the pope really
sharing
the the reality that even though i
never attended um
but still that the effects of them still
linger today a message about residential
schools with both darkness and light we
don't just suffer the intergenerational
effects we also like were passed down
the
intergenerational like legacy of like
healing and
being proud of who we are as first
nations people the delegation of up to
30 people includes residential school
survivors and indigenous leaders they're
calling on pope francis to apologize all
those apologies always fall short
they're always considered not enough and
inadequate
i believe
in vatican they are ready for for this
kind of thing experts say that today
apologies can represent a beginning and
not an end it's one step in a very long
process
so i don't i won't be surprised if some
indigenous leaders find it impossible to
accept an apology it's less of a call
but more of a reminder that that's where
we would like to see this reconciliation
start metis national council president
cassidy karen says extra time allows
them to work on messages and letters
they want to bring for more metis school
survivors we have an opportunity to
share with the pope like i say the metis
nation stories who we are who our
communities are how we represent
ourselves so that when he comes to
canada he understands that there are
three distinct indigenous peoples here
in canada delegates are confident the
trip will happen one tells us a new date
is expected to be released before
christmas
abigail beeman global news ottawa
in india an investigation is underway
after the country's top military general
was killed in a helicopter crash in the
southern state of tamil nadu the indian
air force says general bipin rawat was
among 13 people who died authorities say
the russian-made helicopter he was on
was on a short flight when it went down
in a hilly region the general was chief
of the defense staff and was working to
modernize india's military
in france police have released the man
arrested in connection with the 2018
killing of journalist jamal khashoggi
they say it was a case of mistaken
identity the man from saudi arabia was
arrested yesterday at charles de gaulle
airport in paris on a warrant issued by
turkey the man shared the same name and
age as one of khashoggi's suspected
killers
time to rethink an award given to the
best of the best coming up the push to
rename the trophy awarded to canada's
athlete of the year
[Music]
canadian olympic medalist damian warner
is wrapping up 2021 with another
accolade he has won the lumarsh trophy
as canada's athlete of the year the 32
year old won gold in the decathlon at
the tokyo summer games and broke an
olympic record doing it he also carried
canada's flag during the closing
ceremony
there is no doubt the lou marsh trophy
which has been around for 85 years is
prestigious but now there's a push to
rename it as mike derlea reports it
boils down to marsh's poor track record
damien warner is joining a gilded class
of elite canadian athletes to have won
the lou marsh trophy and he very well
may be the last because while lou marsh
may be regarded by some as a sports
writing pioneer his work also relied on
harmful tropes
and openly stoked racist attitudes in
the early 1900s his legacy goes really
really deep when we think about the
impact the way in which he influenced
the way people thought about athletes
the way
people thought about indigenous people
about black people
about jewish people about women western
university sociologist janice forsyth is
leading review of marsha's work for the
committee that oversees the award that
bears his name and will next decide on
whether or not to rename it which
journalist mark hampshire says is a
no-brainer no no chance is it the blue
marsh award in 2022 when marsh died in
1936 the toronto star dedicated four
pages to its former sports editor a good
indicator as to his influence at the
time the story spoke of him as fearless
ever fair respected while ignoring the
racist comments and epithets which laced
his columns what he routinely wrote
about the great indigenous runner tom
longboat among others is unprintable
today he opposed calls to boycott the
1936 berlin games and while the star's
news pages were filled with stories
about the terrible treatment of jews in
nazi germany marsh called it an internal
german matter so you could say oh sure
that's the way they spoke in those days
no
they didn't speak that way unless
influential people like lou marsh told
them that it was okay to speak that way
forsythe isn't looking to erase marsh's
past she sees him as a historical figure
we can learn from but not necessarily
honor i hope we're at a moment in time
where we can reconsider
the name of this award
for someone who
doesn't have this kind of legacy i think
we're at a moment in time where people
are ready for this kind of change and
you know now's the time to do it perhaps
by honoring someone whose contributions
to canada go beyond sport mike relay
global news toronto
cracking the hot housing market ahead a
new way to help ease the burden of home
buying
the bank of canada is keeping its key
interest rate at a record low the bank
slashed its rate to a quarter of one
percent at the start of the pandemic
it's warning a hike could come sometime
between april and september next year
high inflation rates aren't expected to
fall until the second half of 2022
and with the rising cost of living in
this country budgets are tightening a
toronto company is offering a new way to
break into one of canada's hottest
housing markets it's called co-ownership
and gaviola explains how it works and
why some industry analysts have
reservations
with the average home price in toronto
now nearing 1.2 million dollars and the
median annual salary for people in the
gta only around 60 000 saving enough for
a down payment has never felt more out
of reach there's a large cohort of
canadians that are squeezed out of the
market and they want most of the
benefits of owning with the freedoms and
flexibilities of renting key is a
startup offering co-ownership targeting
young workers who feel priced out
one of the suites on offer is a one
bedroom plus den 600 square foot condo
in a trendy toronto neighborhood valued
at 535 000
for an initial investment of 13 500
buyers get a contract locking in a two
and a half percent equity stake from
there buyers must pay nearly two
thousand dollars monthly but can get on
the path to home ownership gradually
building equity with the option to buy
the property and take on a mortgage
after three years
industry analysts say that's significant
if your name isn't on title it shouldn't
be billed as co-ownership so it is more
like a rents to own scheme
rather than
the way they're marketing it i feel like
what they're presenting is is very very
misleading key says this is a new model
that's different from rent to own and
ownership is spelled out in a legally
binding contract and certain rights over
the property when you have an equity
stake that increases in value with the
underlying asset two you have a say in
what goes on renovations and
customization and three you share in
repairs and maintenance on a pro rata
basis he passes all those ownership
tests former bank of canada governor
stephen poloz is among keys advisors the
startup has 60 units including some in
the building behind me with more than
100 people joining the wait list every
single day it has plans to expand beyond
toronto i think this will appeal to
people that are having difficulty
learning or knowing how to save and
knowing what to do with that money but
then i would take a step back and say if
you're having that difficulty don't
become a homeowner one big unknown is
what mortgage rates will be like in
three years there's still no shortcut to
qualifying and in this case paying a
premium to punt that into the future
ann gaviola global news toronto
next a mysterious fireball lights up
alberta's night sky
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
even with camels every year saudi arabia
hosts a camel beauty pageant and this
year it has cracked down on enhancements
40 camels were reportedly disqualified
from this year's contest they were
judged to have received botox injections
and facelifts and other artificial
touch-ups jurors are supposed to choose
the winner based on the shape of the
camel's heads necks humps stress and
postures but there is a 66 million
dollar prize at stake so you can see why
some camel owners try to push nature
along
some albertans got an unexpected light
show last night cameras caught something
bright and mysterious streaking across
the sky and there was a loud boom some
are wondering if it was a meteorite as
heather urix west explains it wouldn't
be the first
i was just getting ready for bed and
i heard her rumbling caitlyn kostanuk
isn't sure what her doorbell camera
captured in the skies over central
alberta tuesday night my husband and i
immediately went to meteorite
that's what we thought was right off the
hot the
flash came from behind the neighbor's
house whatever it was mandy mcclanahan
heard it too i was watching tv in my
living room with my cat
we were just chilling it was close to 10
and we heard a huge boom my windows all
shook it almost certainly is a meteor
it's not space debris it was moving
certainly too fast for that fireballs
like this one aren't uncommon in
february a bright light streaked across
the skies above calgary edmonton even
saskatoon
a flash followed by a boom can indicate
parts of the meteor have made it way
down to land these pieces were found by
university of calgary researchers in
2017
but in october one hit way too close to
home for ruth hamilton it sounded like
an explosion happening jumped out of bed
ran over and turned on the light and saw
a hole in my roof the space rock landed
on a pillow just centimeters from her
sleeping head
this time around mandy mcclanahan is
grateful it was just some light and
sound didn't hit the house and didn't
hit the cars so we are good heather urex
west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
york canada is the port de grey
peninsula in newfoundland and labrador
all decked out for the holidays we'd
love to see your canada especially
festive and joyful pictures this time of
year please email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you